[Musique]
et qu'elle soit belle je tenais
particulièrement aujourd'hui à remercier
Madame la propriétaire des lieux qui a
cru qui a pas hésité
[Musique]
ce samedi matin au tampon nous avons
l'inauguration d'une maison d'accueil en
familiaux un monsieur et son épouse ont
décidé donc d'investir dans cette map et
ça permet d'accueillir 9 personnes
âgées dans les meilleures conditions
possibles parce que nous nous veut que
l'accueil se fasse dans un cadre
familial le plus longtemps possible nos
aînés doivent rester dans un cadre
familial ces pour cela que nous
soutenons divers projets sur toute la
Réunion il y en a aujourd'hui en tout 8
8 mars qui sont opérationnels et nous
avons que 9 baffes qui vont sortir dans
les temps qui viennent donc très vite
nous aurons 17 mars ce qui représente à
peu près 170 places pour les personnes
âgées le département chaque fois qu'il y
a un projet comme celui-là apporte
150000 euros au promoteur pour investir
dans les locaux pour les aménagements
l'accessibilité et en fonctionnement
nous apportons 100.000 euros chaque
année dans cinq ans et donc nous sommes
assurés à ce moment-là que les locaux
soient bien adaptés pour les personnes
âgées et en même temps que le
fonctionnement soit assuré dans les
meilleures conditions possibles avec des
créations d'emploi nous souhaitons avoir
une marque par commune mais au minimum
autant il y a deux projets de map donc
c'est un mouvement vraiment très fort
notre ambition je vous l'ai dit c'est de
tenir compte du vieillissement de la
population réunionnaise faut savoir que
nous allons passer en l'espace de 30 ans
un doublement du nombre de personnes
âgées à la Réunion donc nous voulons
aller très vite sur ce mouvement de
création de place et en même temps ça
permet de créer des emplois et je vois
ici des visages rayonnants les personnes
qui sont accueillies sont tous souriants
et bien ces merveilleux de voir ça si
cette solidarité qui nous fait plaisir
et en même temps ceux qui travaillent
avec nos énigmes ont aussi le sourire et
bien quand on voit tout cela on est
content et on se dit qu'il faut aller
encore beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup
plus loin
alors la MAAF justement elle a une
capacité d'accueil de 9 personnes
accueillies et trois professionnels tous
les jours qui restent ici le matin et
soir donc on a une capacité de 12
chambres donc comme je vous dis tout à
l'heure donc les personnels et les
diplômés il est formé voilà c'est une
exigence du département c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un devoir
pendant 5 ans avec le département qui va
nous accompagner sur cinq années à
hauteur de 100.000 euros tous les ans et
le but au bout de ces 5 ans c'est qu'on
soit complètement autonome voilà donc je
tenais vraiment à remercier le président
de par sa présence d'aujourd'hui et
également le département pour tous ces
actions sociales pour cette cause
[Musique]